Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Four: Copenhagen.
The name Copenhagen, København, originally means "the Merchants' Harbour".
In the 1000s, the town was a fishing hamlet called Hafn, Harbour.
In 1167, Roskilde's bishop Absalon built a castle on the spot.
The town continued to belong to Roskilde's bishop until 1416, when it was taken over by the king.
That Copenhagen grew up as the country's biggest town has especially to do with its location by the Øresund, and thereby the big, international trade routes into and out of the Baltic Sea.
In addition the town lies in the lee of Amager and thereby has a naturally protected harbour.
The short distance, about 40 kilometres, to Kronborg in Helsingør also made Copenhagen an obvious bastion for the navy to support the guarding of ships' entry and exit through the strait.
In the Middle Ages, roughly 1050 to 1500, the king travelled most of the time around the country with his officials and soldiers.
But during the 1400s and 1500s, Copenhagen gradually became his permanent residence town and thereby the realm's undisputed capital.
It was not least during Christian the Fourth's reign, 1588 to 1648, that Copenhagen grew into a European city.
Christian the Fourth's buildings in Copenhagen.
The building-happy king put his mark on Copenhagen in the 1600s with a long series of striking buildings.
Perhaps the best known and most loved of his buildings is the Round Tower, Rundetårn, from 1642.
It is 41.55 metres high and famous for the 200-metre-long spiral walkway that leads up to the viewing platform.
Here you see the letters RFP, which stand for Christian the Fourth's motto, the Latin Regna firmat pietas, "Piety strengthens the realms".
Christian the Fourth bought, at the beginning of the 1600s, several private plots outside Copenhagen's then ramparts and created the King's Garden, Kongens Have.
Since the 1770s it has been open to everyone, and today it is one of Copenhagen's most popular parks.
In the garden he built a small summerhouse, which was continuously expanded and in 1634 was finished as Rosenborg Castle.
The crown jewels are found in the Treasury at Rosenborg and consist primarily of four large sets of jewellery.
The Queen normally wears them for the New Year's reception and at state visits and other big events.
In the Treasury you also see the so-called crown regalia, namely especially the orb and the sceptre, which symbolise the kings' or queens' power and dignity.
The king wanted to make Copenhagen a European trading centre, and therefore he built the Stock Exchange, Børsen, which was finished in 1640.
The Stock Exchange's characteristic is the Dragon Spire with the four dragon tails that twist around each other.
It is said to protect the house against enemy attacks and fire.
It did not protect any better, however, than that half of the building, including the Dragon Spire, was destroyed by a big fire in April 2024.
The unique neighbourhood Nyboder is also due to Christian the Fourth.
He decided in 1631 that good housing should be built for the navy's soldiers, and the district includes 200 terraced houses of about 40 square metres each.
In the 1700s Nyboder had 6,000 inhabitants; today a good 2,000 people with a connection to the Defence live here.
Amalienborg Palace.
Amalienborg is the royal family's residence in Copenhagen.
The palace is named after Queen Sophie Amalie, who lived from 1628 to 85, and who was married to Frederik the Third.
The Queen had a palace built, which she named after herself: Sophie Amalienborg.
The palace burned down in 1689.
The present palace on the site, where the name is shortened to Amalienborg, has four almost identical mansions, which were built by rich noble families in the 1700s.
In fact it was not meant that the royal family should live at Amalienborg.
But when Christiansborg burned for the first time in 1794, it had nowhere to live and therefore bought Amalienborg.
It is from his reception room in one of the mansions that the king every New Year's Eve, nytårsaften, at 6 pm gives his New Year's speech to the whole realm community.
Older exams said the queen; the answer is New Year's Eve, not Christmas Eve and not Constitution Day.
Amalienborg is where the king and family live; Rosenborg is a museum for the crown jewels.
On special days in the royal house there is a tradition for the king and family to be cheered from the mansion's balcony.
The Royal Life Guards with the big bearskin hats change guard at Amalienborg every day at 12 noon.
On special occasions, for example on the king's birthday, the Life Guards are in red uniforms.
Otherwise the guards are in blue.
Tivoli.
When Tivoli opened in 1843, there was probably nobody who would have believed that an amusement park had been created that would become known in large parts of the world.
Denmark's most visited tourist attraction is known for its exotic architecture and historic buildings.
But in addition there are the fine gardens and rides such as the old wooden roller coaster from 1914.
In the evening thousands of coloured lights create a fairy-tale atmosphere.
Finally there is the Pantomime Theatre, where the oldest of the theatre's pantomime performances are more than 200 years old.
The Little Mermaid, Den lille Havfrue.
The inspiration for the Little Mermaid came from H.C.
Andersen's fairy tale from 1837 of the same name.
It is about a mermaid who falls in love with a prince she cannot have.
This sculpture from 1913, which sits on a stone in Copenhagen Harbour, is only 125 centimetres high, but it is one of Denmark's best known and most visited tourist attractions.
The Little Mermaid has several times been subjected to vandalism, for example by someone painting it with political messages or sawing its head or arms off.
New architecture in Copenhagen.
Copenhagen has developed enormously in recent decades with a series of exciting buildings created by Danish architects.
This is for example Henning Larsen's Opera House from 2005 with a floor area of 41,000 square metres, spread over 14 floors.
The three large light sculptures in the foyer are by Olafur Eliasson, while the four bronze reliefs are made by Per Kirkeby.
The Black Diamond, the library, from 1999 is designed by Schmidt Hammer Lassen and has a large ceiling decoration by Per Kirkeby.
The UN City on Marmormolen, designed by the architecture firm 3XN, is designed as an eight-pointed star.
Here there are 11 UN organisations with 1,500 employees who come from more than 100 countries.
The spectacular housing project 8TALLET, the Eight House, in Ørestad on Amager, is designed by Bjarke Ingels Group, BIG, and was in 2011 named the world's best housing project.
Here is your recap for Episode Four.
Copenhagen means "the Merchants' Harbour".
Absalon built a castle in 1167; the king took the town over from Roskilde's bishop in 1416.
Christian the Fourth's reign, 1588 to 1648, made Copenhagen a European city.
The Round Tower, from 1642, is 41.55 metres high with a 200-metre spiral walkway; Rosenborg was finished in 1634; the Stock Exchange in 1640, with the Dragon Spire, half destroyed by fire in April 2024; Nyboder was decided in 1631.
Amalienborg is the royal residence, with four mansions; the king gives his New Year's speech at 6 pm on New Year's Eve; the Life Guards change guard at 12 noon.
Tivoli opened in 1843 and is Denmark's most visited tourist attraction.
The Little Mermaid sculpture is from 1913 and 125 centimetres high.
The Opera House is from 2005, the Black Diamond from 1999, the UN City has 11 UN organisations, and 8TALLET was named the world's best housing project in 2011.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which king is behind the building of, among other things, the Round Tower and Rosenborg Castle in Copenhagen?
Option A: Christian the Fourth.
Option B: Christian the Seventh.
Option C: Christian the Tenth.
[DA] Hvilken konge står bag opførelsen af blandt andet Rundetårn og Rosenborg Slot i København?  A: Christian den 4.  |  B: Christian den 7.  |  C: Christian den 10.
The answer is A: Christian the Fourth.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Christian den 4.
Question 2.
On which of the following days of observance does the head of state give a speech every year to the whole realm community?
The exam says the queen; today it is the king.
Option A: Christmas Eve.
Option B: New Year's Eve.
Option C: Constitution Day.
[DA] På hvilken af følgende mærkedage holder dronningen hvert år en tale til hele rigsfællesskabet?  A: Juleaften  |  B: Nytårsaften  |  C: Grundlovsdag
The answer is B: New Year's Eve.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nytårsaften
Question 3.
Which historic building in Copenhagen burned on the sixteenth of April 2024?
Option A: Holmens Church.
Option B: The Stock Exchange, Børsen.
Option C: Rosenborg Castle.
[DA] Hvilken historisk bygning i København brændte den 16. april 2024?  A: Holmens Kirke  |  B: Børsen  |  C: Rosenborg Slot
The answer is B: The Stock Exchange, Børsen.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Børsen
Question 4.
In which castle in Copenhagen does the king and his family live part of the year?
Option A: Christiansborg.
Option B: Rosenborg.
Option C: Amalienborg.
[DA] På hvilket slot i København bor kongen og hans familie en del af året?  A: Christiansborg  |  B: Rosenborg  |  C: Amalienborg
The answer is C: Amalienborg.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Amalienborg
That's the end of this part.
Well done.